hey 42 here we humans like to think of
ourselves as the Undisputed masters of
planet Earth we have arduously evolved
over hundreds of thousands of years the
advanced adaptations required to survive
in a slightly warm living room with the
aid of advanced technology our
civilization has settled in every
petrified pocket and withered Wasteland
on this wicked world except that's not
entirely true as of today humans can be
found in significantly less than one
percent of all livable locations on
Earth
at first that might sound hard to
believe aside from the tallest mountains
the hottest deserts and that Brazilian
Island full of snakes we've
built permanent settlements pretty much
everywhere haven't we
actually not even close for the simple
reason that well over 99 of the planet's
habitable space is found in the world's
oceans and as of today we've colonized
precisely none of it
from our Terra Firma first perspective
it's easy to underestimate the sheer
scale of the underwater world there are
over a billion cubic kilometers of water
in Earth's combined oceans and the
Mariana Trench the deepest point on the
ocean floor is a staggering 6.8 miles
beneath the surface
just saying that number 6.8 miles
doesn't really give you a sense of just
how far down we're talking here so let's
make a comparison the world's tallest
building the Burj Khalifa in Dubai is
almost twice the height of the Empire
State Building
and yet you could stack 13 Burj khalifas
one on top of the other in the Mariana
Trench and you still wouldn't break the
surface
that dear 42 viewer is absolutely bloody
mental now I do a lot of work whilst
traveling and surfsharkvpn keeps me safe
and private by covering up everything I
do online when I'm out and about but
surfsharkvpn also lets you travel the
world virtually by changing your virtual
location so you can check out websites
on streaming services from all around
the world that may be blocked in your
home country surfshark has over 3200
servers in over 100 countries so
anywhere you go you'll find a server
that fits your needs and surfsharkvpn
offers a multi-hub feature so you can
actually put two VPN servers between you
and your online destination for even
more privacy and security I especially
love surfshark's IP Rotator feature
which constantly changes your device's
IP address without losing your VPN
connection online security is so
important and it's really nice to know
that with surfsharkvpn I can for example
access my online banking safely even on
public Wi-Fi I'd never do that without a
VPN vpns also keep your location and
download history private so you can send
and receive files securely quite simply
surfsharkvpn is an essential tool and by
using the Code 42 you'll benefit from an
83 discount plus free extra months for
free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description below so
don't miss out and thanks to surfshark
for sponsoring this video
most of the ocean is significantly
shallower than the Mariana Trench but
the global average depth is still a
healthy 2.3 miles and pretty much all of
that space is habitable considering its
sheer size it should come as no surprise
that the ocean is home to some 78
percent of Earth's total animal biomass
near the surface that biomass comes in
the form of animals that are fairly
familiar whales sharks brightly colored
fish sexy mermaids that sort of thing
but dive a little deeper and the Deluge
of disturbing creatures awaits
at 400 meters you'll meet the Monstrous
goblin shark whose extendable jaw can be
catapulted forward to engulf
unsuspecting prey
descend further to around 1 000 meters
and a humorous respite awaits you in the
form of the Blobfish multiple winner of
the ugliest animal alive award that's
actually a thing by the way
sink further Still Into the shadowy
Depths to 2000 meters below and you'll
encounter the ghastly gulper eel a
creature that brings new meaning to the
phrase all mouth and no trousers
but it isn't just weird fish you'll find
in this watery Abyss Nature's wettest
Workshop also breeds Giants from the
Kraken to yorman Gand we've been telling
stories of sea monsters for thousands of
years and perhaps there's good reason
for that because thanks to a phenomenon
known as deep sea gigantism many
creatures that have evolved to live in
the darkest ocean depths are
significantly larger than similar
species found in the shallows
probably the most famous example of deep
sea gigantism is the giant squid
reaching a maximum length of 13 meters
and weighing in at over 250 kilograms
this substantial cephalopod is literally
hundreds of times larger than many of
its shallow water cousins the giant
squid is a genuine monster of the deep
but it turns out this great giant has a
great big brother a much much bigger
brother the aptly named colossal squid
weighing as much as three times more
than the already enormous giant squid
the colossal squid is the largest
invertebrate on planet Earth with eyes
the size of basketballs and hooked
suckers capable of leaving sperm whales
with permanent scars but if that doesn't
freak you out here's a subsurface
specimen that'll give you mental scars
this little critter is a giant isopod if
it looks strangely familiar that's
probably because it's closely related to
the humble wood laughs a well-fed
woodlouse is about a centimeter long and
weighs less than a gram soaking wet the
giant isopod on the other hand can grow
close to half a meter and weighs almost
two kilograms
everywhere we look in the deepest
darkest depths of the ocean we see a
similar story familiar looking animals
that have been mysteriously dinosized
like the Japanese spider crab with a leg
span of up to four meters
and the giant oarfish sometimes known as
the king of herrings which can reach a
maximum length of around 11 meters 11
meters it's like God turned up to work
drunk on the fifth day and made a bunch
of rounding errors
so just what the hell is going on here
what's causing deep sea species to grow
so freakishly large the truth is we
aren't actually 100 sure as you're
probably already aware we know
surprisingly little about the ocean
floor in fact up until 2019 more people
had walked on the surface of the Moon
than had visited the deepest part of the
Mariana Trench Challenger Deep the sheer
remoteness of deep ocean environments
makes their manned the creatures that
live there incredibly difficult to study
take the colossal squid as a prime
example as long as a London bus and
weighing more than a fully grown polar
bear you'd think it'd be pretty bloody
hard to miss and yet with all our fancy
technology and remotely operated
submersibles not a single colossal squid
has ever been observed in its natural
habitat not one and since we never get
to bag ourselves one of these beasties
researching to the causes of deep sea
gigantism has proved rather difficult
but we do have some surprising theories
the first is that food scarcity is the
primary cause the idea that a lack of
food could somehow stimulate the
evolution of larger animals might sound
like nonsense surely the opposite would
happen right but to dive a little deeper
into the science and this apparent
contradiction starts to make a lot of
sense unlike almost every other
ecosystem on the planet the ocean depths
have close to zero food production of
Their Own
no light means no photosynthesis and no
photosynthesis means no phytoplankton
which is the main producer of food near
the surface
as a result the primary food source in
the deep sea is so-called Marine snow a
deep ocean delicacy Marine snow is
basically a mix of dead animals decaying
phytoplankton and a whole load of fish
that slowly drifts into the abyss
from the shallow Waters above sounds
delicious
Marine snow supplemented by the
carcasses of larger animals is consumed
as it falls meaning the deeper you get
the less there is to go around that
makes food on the ocean bottom both
scarce and unpredictable there isn't a
great deal of it and you never know
where the juiciest morsels will land
for a bottom-dwelling scavenger like the
giant isopod being bigger means it can
cover longer distances more quickly
increasing its foraging radius and
improving its chances of being the first
on the scene when food does drift so
deliciously downwards
large animals are also able to store
more food than smaller ones helping them
to survive long periods without
sustenance
many deep sea creatures have evolved
extendable stomachs that allow them to
take in the maximum amount of food
possible on the rare occasions a solid
meal presents itself
the results can be surprising a giant
isopod with the catchy nickname giant
isopod one once went five years without
eating a single thing presumably in
protest at its imprisonment in the Toba
aquarium in Japan
five years without food is undeniably
supermodel tear dieting but these long
fast are made possible by another
benefit of increased size a more
efficient metabolism according to
clybers law an animal's metabolic rate
scales to the three-quarters power of
its mass
to translate that into normal person
English larger animals need less energy
per unit of mass than smaller ones
a mouse for example needs to eat up to
20 of its body weight every single day
to survive whereas an elephant only
needs to consume four or five percent of
its body weight
in other words larger animals use energy
more efficiently and that is a massive
bonus in an environment where food is
scarce
now the other Theory as to why creatures
of the deep grow so big is related to
temperature because cold water is denser
and therefore heavier than warm water it
sinks and that means deep sea
environments are extremely cold frigid
temperatures inhibits the speed of
metabolic processes decreasing the
amount of food and oxygen required to
sustain life a slower metabolism is also
thought to be part of the reason many
deep sea creatures grow slower and live
longer than similar species in shallower
waters
as an extreme example Recent research
suggests that the bottom dwelling
Greenland shark may be able to live to
well over 500 years old making it the
longest living vertebrate ever
discovered
just think about that for a second there
may be a Greenland shark swimming around
today that was alive when Leonardo da
Vinci painted the Mona Lisa in the early
16th century
the idea that lower temperatures play a
role in deep sea gigantism is backed up
by the fact that we also see something
called polar gigantism a tendency for
species that live in frigid Waters of
the Arctic and southern oceans to
exhibit gigantism even in Shallow Waters
sea spiders are a great example in most
parts of the world sea spiders are
relatively tiny thankfully from a few
millimeters to a couple of centimeters
across the Antarctic sea spider on the
other hand has a nightmare inducing 70
centimeter leg span easily big enough to
latch onto your face and inject
thousands of babies directly down your
throat similar massive increases in body
size can be seen in polar sponges worms
starfish and even single-celled
organisms
so we've got the food scarcity Theory
and the temperature Theory but there's
also a far simpler reason deep sea
species have evolved to get so big there
are significantly fewer Predators down
there
that's allowed mother nature to be a
little Bolder with the body sizes of
species that might traditionally stay
small to attract less attention from
things that might want to eat them
the truth is there's probably no single
unifying explanation for deep sea
gigantism and different variables will
play a bigger role in some species than
others it's also worth pointing out that
plenty of Abyssal creatures exhibit the
exact opposite effect deep sea dwarfism
which is a clear indicator that this
little puzzle is unlikely to have a
simple answer ultimately the deep ocean
is a chance to see how life somehow
finds a way in one of the most
inhospitable environments on planet
Earth
thanks for watching
[Music]